piranha 3dd I really can't keep a
straight face I saw piranha 3dd it's the
sequel to piranha 3d which you know was
kind of like a gleefully fun movie you
know it was more self-aware of what it
was it really isn't much fun going to
the plot the fish are back and they're
eating people and there's a whole bunch
of teens who like the idea of sex and
there's a bunch of fish that want to eat
them and the teens when I have sex but
the fish are getting in the way
basically now before I get into my
review you're probably thinking one or
two things why do you even see this
movie I mean you know who cares it's
obviously it looks terrible
because I honestly try to see as many
movies as I can because I want to review
them for you guys I want to be able to
see what they're like and I want to be
able to see if I can have some fun and
reviewing a piece of cinematic trash and
the other thing you're probably thinking
is look Chris yes okay this movie's dumb
but it's supposed to be dumb it's
supposed to be stupid you shouldn't bash
it because it's supposed to be done no
that's a pass that is a pass my friend
it's just an excuse you know to say oh
we can do it everyone because we're
trying to make a horrible movie there is
a difference between a film that is so
bad that it's good and a film that is so
bad that it's just bad this film has no
idea how to be so bad that it's good
this is just an absolutely horrible
movie this is one of the worst movies
I've seen in a while let me tell you how
this movies directed okay if I gave my
sister's dog a video camera and strapped
it around his collar and just let him
walk around a water park and whatever is
gonna happen happens there is literally
nothing to this direction there is not
one good shot in this movie it is the
laziest film I have seen in so long it's
not funny at all and the only times I
laughed out loud was when I was like oh
that is that was dumb I'm a guy that
will laugh at movies that are so bad
they're good okay like The Wicker Man
with Nicolas Cage man that's an awful
movie I guarantee there's no other movie
you can see a guy running around in a
bear suit punching people that is funny
because you can tell that when they were
making it they were they actually we're
trying to make something good and it
just went all wrong this movie has
nothing to recommend it all those boobs
in it what would you do search on the
internet there's boobs all over the
Internet why you have to go into theater
for $14 to see boobs there's no reason
to do that
so stupid so see like this movie is
redeeming in some way because there's
nudity in it that means nothing
countless movies out there have been
unity and it doesn't mean it's good ah
sorry and what really surprised me this
movie like promotes itself as really
gory and lots of over-the-top fish core
it's really not it's really actually
toned down in a lot of ways there's
really only two scenes in this movie I
was like because it was so disgusting
but it wasn't that I was shocked by how
outrageous the gore was it made no sense
there's a scene in this movie where a
woman magically has a piranha come out
of her vagina for no reason and bite off
with you guys penis I mean why any
moment in this movie that you thought
looked good from the trailer it's cuz
that's the only parts that are good in
the movie the big slow-mo shot of a girl
running as breasts bigger than
basketballs first off that's not even
attractive okay if you're attracted to
that you've obviously never felt a
woman's breasts before okay I'm just
saying that's the truth there is
actually a dream sequence there's a
dream sequence a dream sequence when is
the last time that a dream sequence ever
worked when is the last time when an
audience didn't go oh when the person
wakes up when is that ever worked who
said that was a good idea I want to know
who in Hollywood said yes piranha 3dd we
will make this movie we know it's gonna
be horrible but we should definitely a
dream sequence in there just to piss a
whole bunch of people off like seriously
who said that was a good idea this movie
has absolutely nothing that I can
recommend from it it is is really bad
and there really is no point in me going
on anymore I'm sure you guys knew that
the only reason I even made this review
is because a lot of you guys enjoy it
with my when I hate on a movie and yeah
I mean I'm not telling anything
surprising don't see piranha 3dd if
you're a fan of the first one to be
honest I wouldn't even see this one
because it'll just make you feel bad you
know like it's like one of those sequels
where it just comes out and you're like
oh you want to see women's breasts
seriously either
get yourself a girlfriend get married or
go on Google I'm going to get front a 3d
D&F it's the worst movie I've seen so
far this year no big surprises here but
on the
bright side I will be seeing Prometheus
pretty soon looking forward to that that
should be a good movie that should be a
fun time I'm looking forward to that
movie Wow and as always guys if you
liked this review you can subscribe to
my channel and get stuck mine eyes